I followed the process around an open
center and I'm very curious about you
know what defines a center I I know the
work of the architect david chipperfield
why would I know David quite well as
well and followed his you know
sensitivity and very sincere respect to
the relationship between the building
and its surroundings i mean the public
space here i think is a clean complete
component and as we know stockholm and
sweden in general has a very strong
history in public space meaning that the
space on the street is something that
people really own I think the noble
identity is something that sweets has
taken to the heart so there's a strong
sense of ownership a degree of pride and
so on so I am very curious about you
know how the center will actually
amplify exactly what is already there
you know people are so proud about the
Nobel this it is so you know conscious
about its its own space it has a slight
sort of museological tendency you know
everything has to look old so that's
maybe you know a challenge for stuff
going to be a little bit ahead of itself
so if I if I can criticize a little bit
also so I think the the noble center
very much brings in a contemporary
statement that I think also allows for
strong sense of public identity of
public feeling to grow from that we
should not underestimate its gonna be
the program I mean the activities in the
building they know that the future Nobel
prizes that's what that's what a gun
that's going to give the identity to the
building the building is not going to
color the Nobel Prizes the Nobel prizes
are going to create the building right
so we also have to put in architecture
at its right point and you know the city
is hosting the building and I think they
would have been very sensitive to the
fact that the city's you know a space of
hospitality in which this building
sitting so the building also gains its
identity and its shape and its language
from the city so we very often talk
about the building as if it's somehow
standing alone on the moon or something
but that's not the case the building is
full of all these driving forces the
activities the great noble sort of
narrative
and this is I think how we see it and
what gives me confidence in the project
is that this is how David Chipperfield
see city itself he's not he's very
unselfish in that way